Everybody, Ashley here, I want to discuss today magnesium L-theanate.
This form of magnesium can cross our blood brain barrier.
When it does that, it actually boosts our magnesium levels in our brains, which is vital
for cognition.
There have been studies shown that it improves individual performance on cognitive tests.
It also supports our short and long-term memory as well as our learning ability.
We have even been studies to show that it helps the symptoms for Alzheimer's and dementia,
and it can also help our sleep management, our stress levels, and anxiety.
In a huge perk of magnesium L-theanate that research has shown is it can even reverse brain
aging.
So you can find magnesium L-theanate in a product that we have of Conor's Clinic brand called
Clear Meg Neuro.
You can get it in lime or in berry.
So either one is great depends on what flavor you like, of course, but these contain magnesium
L-theanate.
So if you're looking for a really good brain health support, this product is a really good
one for you to at least check out.
So you can find that on shop.conorsclinic.com and you can find Clear Meg Neuro is what you'll
be looking for.
Thank you.